ELECTIONS.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, EVERY
ELECTION CYCLE YOU PROBABLY
NOTICE MORE STATES LEGALIZE
MARIJUANA.
IT COULD BE LEGAL NATIONWIDE
AND LIKELY WILL BE.
WITH DRUG ABUSE OF ALL KINDS
SOARING AND THE AMERICAN YOUTH
FALLING APART IS LEGALIZATION
A GOOD IDEA?
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT
MARIJUANA?
WE HAVE THE AUTHOR OF "HOW TO
SMOKE POT PROPERLY" AND
CO-HOST OF THE PODCAST "GREAT
MOMENTS IN WEED HISTORY."
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THE FIRST THING I
NOTICE IS THERE AN INTERESTING
PIECE BY MALCOLM GLADWELL IN
THE "NEW YORKER" AND HE IS
AGNOSTIC ABOUT THE QUESTION OF
MARIJUANA BUT HE MADE THE
QUESTION WE DON'T KNOW THAT
MUCH OF THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
THE MARIJUANA.
MOST OF THE CLAIMS MADE BY THE
OPPONENTS ARE UNPROVEN.
BUT THE C.D.C. DOES SAY THERE
IS A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
MARIJUANA USE AND THE RISING
SCHIZOPHRENIA RATES AND
VIOLENCE.
WHY SHOULD WE LEGALIZE
SOMETHING WE KNOW CAUSES
SCHIZOPHRENIA?
>> WELL, I MEAN THE FIRST
THING WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND IS
CANNABIS IS OBJECTIVELY SAFER
THAN MANY SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
LEGAL.
ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO WITH, AND
MANY PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS.
TO GET TO YOUR POINT --
>> Tucker: WAIT.
CAN WE PAUSE FOR A SECOND.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT IT'S SAFER
THAN ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO?
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW MUCH
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE BEEN STUDYING
NICOTINES FOR HUNDREDS OF
YEARS AND ALCOHOL FOR
THOUSANDS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT
THEM.
WHY DO WE SAY WE KNOW THAT
WHEN WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
THAT?
>> WE CAN COMPARE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO DIE FROM EACH
SUBSTANCE EVERY YEAR.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM ALCOHOL AND
TOBACCO AND ZERO PEOPLE FROM
CANNABIS.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> SHORTHAND --
>> Tucker: NO.
THAT IS NOT ACTUALLY TRUE.
>> ATTRIBUTED TO THE --
ABSOLUTELY IT'S TRUE.
SAYING SOMETHING IS NOT
TRUE --
>> Tucker: WELL, I'M GOING
TO.
IF IT IS TRUE, AS THE C.D.C.
SAYS CANNABIS USE LOOKS LIKE
IT PAUSES AND SPURS --
>> WHAT IS A LEGAL DOSE OF
CANNABIS?
>> Tucker: WAIT --
>> ANSWER MY QUESTION.
>> Tucker: WAIT.
NO.
I'M SAYING YOU ARE LOOKING AT
IT WRONG.
IF WEED SMOKING CAUSES
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND THERE IS A
SUGGESTION THAT IT DOES,
SCHIZOPHRENIA KILLS LOTS OF
PEOPLE AND SO DOES SUICIDE AND
VIOLENCE.
IF MARIJUANA USE HIKES RATES
OF VIOLENCE AND IT SEEMS THERE
IS A LOT OF EVIDENCE IT DOES,
THEN IT KILLS PEOPLE.
SO THE QUESTION IS DO THEY DIE
FROM SUICIDE OR VIOLENCE?
THOSE ARE THE REAL QUESTIONS.
YOU DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THEM.
WHY ARE YOU SAYING IT'S
TOTALLY SAFE IF YOU DON'T KNOW
IT'S TRUE?
>> I DID NOT SAY IT'S TOTALLY
SAFE.
THAT IS A RIDICULOUS STANDARD.
STRENUOUS EXERCISE CAN LEAD TO
A HEART ATTACK THAT IS FATAL.
DRINKING TOO MUCH WATER CAN BE
FATAL.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CORRELATION
AND CAUSATION.
>> Tucker: I DO UNDERSTAND.
>> APPARENTLY YOU DON'T.
>> Tucker: NO, I DO.
WHAT I UNDERSTAND MOST OF ALL
IS THE BASIC PRECIP OF SCIENCE
WE DON'T KNOW SOMETHING UNTIL
WE PROVE IT.
ALMOST NOTHING ABOUT MARIJUANA
IS PROVEN.
WHY ARE YOU ACTING LIKE WE
KNOW WHEN WE DON'T?
>> THIS IS WHAT IS PROVEN TO
BE HARMFUL, TUCKER.
ARRESTS 600,000 AMERICANS
EVERY YEAR FOR MAKING THE
CHOICE TO USE A SUBSTANCE THAT
OBJECTIVELY IS SAFER THAN
ALCOHOL.
AND DOING IT IN A WAY THAT
TARGETS THE POOR AND
MINORITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IS DEVASTATING TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
>> Tucker: BUT I'M NOT
ARGUING -- YOU ARE MISSING.
I'M NOT ARGUING IN FAVOR OF
THAT.
YOU ARE MAKING A PARALLEL
ARGUMENT --
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO ARREST
ANYBODY FOR CANNABIS?
>> Tucker.
I'M ALWAYS FOR FAIR
APPLICATION OF -- I HAVE NEVER
BEEN ROUSTING PEOPLE FROM
THEIR HOMES FOR SMOKING WEED.
BUT THAT IS DIFFERENT TO LEGAL
I IT EVERYWHERE THAT WILL
INCREASE KIDS SMOKING WEED.
IF IT'S CAUSING SCHIZOPHRENIA,
THEN I SHOULD BE AFRAID OF
THAT, NO?
>> YOUTH USE IS DOWN IN STATES
THAT LEGALIZED FIRST OF ALL.
SECOND OF ALL, IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE LEGALIZED ME, ANSWER ME
THIS.
WHO WILL GROW AND SELL THE
CANNABIS?
WHERE WILL IT MAGICALLY APPEAR
FROM IF NOT THROUGH A
REGULATED TAXED INDUSTRY?
IF MY AUNT IN KANSAS COMES
DOWN WITH CANCER WHERE AM I
GOING TO SEND HER TO BUY A
SAFE, LAB-TESTED MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCT TO SAVE HER
LIFE IN YOUR SYSTEM?
WHO GROWS AND SELLS THE
CANNABIS?
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT IT WAS
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT GREW IT IN
MISSISSIPPI FOR YEARS AS YOU
KNOW.
>> FOR SEVEN PEOPLE, TUCKER.
FOR SEVEN PEOPLE.
>> I GET IT.
BUT IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE --
HOLD ON.
>> WHO IS GOING TO GROW AND
SELL IT IN YOUR SYSTEM?
>> Tucker: AGAIN, YOU ARE
THROWING ANOTHER RED HERRING
IN THE ARGUMENT AND EVADING
THE QUESTION.
>> THAT IS NOT A RED HERRING.
>> Tucker: WE USE OPIOIDS
LEGALLY, THEY ARE PRESCRIBED
BY PHYSICIANS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE AVERAGE
PERSON CAN BUY OPIUM.
SO YOU CAN HAVE CONTROLLED
MARIJUANA GROWING FOR THE
MEDICINAL PROPERTIES WHICH I'M
WILLING TO BELIEVE EXIST.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
LEGALIZING IT THAT MEANS MANY
MORE KIDS WILL SMOKE IT.
IF IT CAUSES SCHIZOPHRENIA IT
SHOULD SCARE THE HELL OUT OF
US.
BUT IT DOESN'T BOTHER YOU
BECAUSE WHAT, YOU TAKE MONEY
FROM THEM?
WHY DOESN'T IT BOTHER YOU?
>> YOU ARE THE ONE ON HERE
REPEATING OLD LIES, AND
DISTORTION AND DEBUNKED CLAIM.
THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK YOU HAD
ON LAST WEEK, EVERYTHING HE
SAID HAS BEEN DEBUNKED.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU READ MY
ARTICLE.
I ASSUME THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE
ME ON.
>> Tucker: NO.
>> MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
STUDIES THAT HE CITED HAVE
GONE ON TWITTER TO SAY YOU
GROSSLY MISREPRESENTED OUR
FINDINGS.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
MEDICINE?
I'M NOT AN EXPERT IN THIS.
>> THE AUTHOR SAID --
>> YOU ARE NOT AN EXPERT BUT
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO DO YOUR
JOB, SUPPOSED TO LEARN
ABOUT -- DID YOU READ MY
ARTICLE WHERE I DEBUNKED ALL
OF THIS?
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK A
QUESTION.
THIS IS MY REAL CONCERN IS
SCHIZOPHRENIA, BECAUSE IT'S A
TERRIBLE DISEASE AND WE CAN'T
CURE IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIE FROM IT
AND IT'S HORRIBLE, AS YOU
KNOW.
IT'S UNTRUE, DO YOU THINK THAT
MARIJUANA USE LOOKS LIKE IT
COULD INCREASE SCHIZOPHRENIA?
IS THAT A FAKE STATISTIC?
THAT IS A SINCERE QUESTION FOR
YOU.
>> WE NEED TO KNOW MORE AND WE
SHOULD KNOW MORE.
BUT HAVING YOU AND AUTHORS
COME ON AND JUST CONFUSE
CAUSATION AND CORRELATION DOES
NO ONE A GOOD SERVICE.
>> Tucker: I'M ASKING YOU A
SINCERE QUESTION.
>> THIS IS MY SINCERE ANSWER.
WE HAVE HAD SOCIETY WHERE THE
RATES OF CANNABIS USE GONE UP
AND RATES OF SCHIZOPHRENIA
HAVE NOT GONE UP AT ALL.
SO TO ME THAT WOULD PUT A LOT
OF COLD WATER ON YOUR IDEA
THAT THERE IS AN EPIDEMIC OF
VIOLENCE --
>> Tucker: AND I THOUGHT YOU
WERE LECTURING ME ABOUT
CORRELATION AND CAUSATION?
LOOK, I HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN
BANNING ANYTHING BUT I THINK
WE DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH.
>> WHY DID YOU HAVE ME ON IF
YOU HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN